the city of bores the center of
Senegal's fishing industry here catches
are still good but the country's
population is growing so demand is on
the rise and more and more fishermen are
casting their nets in the same waters
will there be enough fish to feed
everyone in the future mathematicians
are trying to find out this fishermen
are taking a break that gives kwabena
whoa so the chance to tell them about
his research project the doctoral
student comes from Ghana so is
Senegalese colleague translates for him
their team is looking for fishermen to
take part in an experiment and in that
case we need each of you to help us with
that because you had a main people on
the ground learning the language were
using a cell phone app the fishermen
will report the amounts of fish they
caught and how long they were at sea you
also be looking at a way we can sustain
the fisheries and all to distract from
the experiments will be analyzed
statistically and after that we actually
model it's using my belief revision
models medicine I bunch of monitors and
with that it is hope that it will help
to design and implement the continued
improvement of the fisheries the
researchers never lose sight of the
reason for their research they can see
the ocean from their workplace at the
african institute for mathematical
sciences or aims for short established
four years ago the center in senegal is
part of a pan-african network of ames
institutes they nurture the mathematical
skills of the continents brightest
students the students here are among the
best from their respective countries and
we get to the end different cultures
will get to be your friend languages
yeah so they learn more than just math
here these young people are also engaged
in intercultural exchange where they
discover what life is like in other
African countries here they also make
contacts maybe one of us will be a
politician I don't know or a big
decision maker and so this will be
really easy for us to discuss because we
know each other and we know like the
culture or a [ __ ] from the culture for
the other countries the spectrum of
research is broad spanning both
theoretical and applied mathematics and
top researchers from around the globe
come here to give lectures and workshops
whether the mathematicians will be able
to help the fishermen of Bor remains
unclear but their research shows that
they're serious about trying to improve
life in Africa